David Rubinstein is a billionaire who
previously co-founded Carlyle Group
Carlisle groups got 385 billion dollars
of assets under management and David is
estimated to be worth 3.3 billion
dollars himself and it's interesting
because David Rubenstein also has a show
with Bloomberg where he interviews some
of the top investors around the world
over the years many of these investors
haven't been that excited about Bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies but recently David
Rubinstein hosted Mike novogratz who's
the Galaxy digital co-founder and CEO
Mike previously worked at Fortress and
that's where he learned about Bitcoin
and he bought a bunch of it personally
along with a number of other employees
at Fortress bitcoin's price has
drastically increased from about a
hundred dollars at that time to today it
sits right around thirty thousand
dollars and so David Rubenstein talking
to Mike novogratz was fascinating
because we got to see into the mind of
one of the leaders the cryptocurrency
space but then David Rubinstein having
had that conversation he went on a
Bloomberg show and they started to ask
him all about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies the conversation is
fascinating because we have the Carlisle
Group co-founder somebody who's worth
billions of dollars himself now talking
about Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies in a
very different way then he and his peers
were talking about it just a few years
ago here's a short clip from that
conversation where David rubison has
asked over and over and over again about
Bitcoin and he continues to have
impressive answers and rational thought
around why Bitcoin is going to last and
why he thinks investors will continue to
pour Capital into the asset here's
exactly what David had to say this is
perfectly timed because Nova grass has
been the pinata of Bitcoin when it goes
down it's been the genius of Bitcoin
when it goes up and all of a sudden
Larry showed up at the door to say hey a
big respectable firms can prosecute and
do Bitcoin link Lawrence Fink of
BlackRock to Mike novogratz wow what's
happened is people as you suggest make
fun of Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies but now the
establishment of Larry Fink at uh at
BlackRock is now saying they're going to
have an ETF if approved by the
government in Bitcoin so you're saying
wait a second if the mighty BlackRock is
willing to have an ETF in Bitcoin maybe
Bitcoin is going to be around for a
while Lisa wants to jump in here but I'm
going to cut to the news moment as
Carlisle announcing this morning a
Bitcoin advocacy no I don't think so but
there's no doubt that Bitcoin is
something that I wish I had bought it at
a hundred dollars a Bitcoin when when
Mike novograd started buying it it's now
at twenty nine thousand dollars so he's
made a lot of money and a lot of people
who bought it at the hundred dollars or
less are feeling pretty good now it went
up as high as 61 000 I think even down
to Thirty One Thousand or even 29 000
now it's still pretty good profit if you
bought in 100. we all wish we would have
bought it at 100 uh and to write it up
it's one thing for BlackRock to come up
with an ETF because they believe the
proposition of Bitcoin it's another
because they see a profitability uh
proposition where they can you know
basically take advantage of the interest
other people have I mean isn't that more
of what this is that basically Wall
Street is saying if there is a market
for it and we can viably make one for
them and make some money why not well
remember Wall Street is in business to
make money and this is something they
can probably make money of you have to
remember the United States uh government
has been somewhat skeptical of it I
think Democrats in the Congress and
particularly the people regulating the
SEC are skeptical of Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies but outside the United
States there's a lot of interest in it I
think FTX really hurt when it went
bankrupt and it hurt the the crypto
industry but a lot of people around the
world want to be able to trade in a
currency that their government can't
know what they have and they want to be
able to move it around rightly or
wrongly and so I don't think Bitcoin is
going away I think the Republicans on
Capitol Hill have been pretty supportive
of it there's a difference between uh
having a seamless cross currency payment
basically saying that instead of going
to Western Union I can go and just
transfer something in Bitcoin if it has
a stable enough price that's one
proposition but the proposition of
Bitcoin is a store of value that could
kind of be bid up the way that gold or
silver could seems to have been parked
with the Advent of yield suddenly that
you can get for actual money I mean
isn't that sort of the feeling that
you're getting well there's no doubt
that when when uh interest rates are as
high as they are you don't need to have
gold or other kinds of things to get you
some solid return because when you get
five percent on treasuries but
eventually five percent will be coming
down at some point I don't think Bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies that are the better
ones the better known ones Bitcoin so a
number of others are going to go away
there's enormous interest around the
world and being able to have something
you can transfer without the government
knowing about it and keep it private and
uh you know you can say with people
shouldn't do that but that's not going
to stop people from doing it Mr
novogratz on Mr Gensler what did he say
about the efforts of our chairman of the
Securities and Exchange Commission well
Gary Gensler who's the chairman of the
SEC is not a big fan of of
cryptocurrency I think that's fair to
say but he lost the major case recently
in court where he was trying to argue
that uh one of the cryptocurrencies
Ripple was uh was a security and he lost
that case so I think the SEC has not
been able to convince these the
government yet or at least the courts
that uh cryptocurrency is such a
dangerous thing and I remember a lot of
people in the government now are
thinking that Gary gunster won't be the
chairman of the SEC forever wanted to go
I mean these guys just weighed them out
right I think that's a strategy that's
very popular in Washington waiting out
Regulators you don't like now what's
fascinating to me is not only that David
Rubinstein is having this conversation
on national television and he's openly
talking about the fact that people are
going to continue to invest in Bitcoin
but he specifically said two things that
I want to call attention to the first is
he talks about part of the value
proposition of Bitcoin is that it is
antithetical to the government's view on
centralization of the monetary policy
now that is something that historically
has been reserved for people on Twitter
kind of the conspiracy theory crowd or
maybe the libertarian crowd but now we
have a multi-billionaire who co-founded
one of the largest Asset Management
firms in the world saying whether the
United States government weather
regulators and whether people in the
traditional Financial system like it or
not there are millions if not hundreds
of millions or billions of people around
the world who find that aspect of
Bitcoin quite compelling and it is a
major driver of why they would continue
to allocate Capital into the asset so
now that Secret's kind of out there in
the open people are talking about it and
it's being viewed by people who are part
of the establishment not as a negative
but actually as a positive a huge piece
of investing is to not just take your
own personal opinion or your own
personal views and go ahead and try to
figure out if everyone agrees with you
or not the best investors understand
that the better thing to do is
understand what do other people think
how is the market going to react and if
if you realize that there is a large
portion of the global population that
wants to have a decentralized digital
currency that is not controlled by their
government or by their central bank then
obviously Bitcoin will continue to be
valuable in the future now the second
thing that David talked about in this
interview is the fact that BlackRock is
coming in with their ETF application he
basically says listen black rock is this
Mighty asset manager and if they're
going to go ahead and put forward an ETF
application then of course they've got a
high likelihood of thinking it's going
to get approved if you remember I've
talked about it previously blackrock's
record when it comes to ETF applications
is 575 wins to one loss literally 575
out of 576 applications have been
approved and so it is highly likely that
they are going to actually get this
approved now we just saw that the
Federal Reserve announced a brand new
oversight mechanism for the
cryptocurrency market that lends more
credibility to the fact that people
believe that BlackRock and other ETF
applications for a Bitcoin spot ETF will
be approved Mike novograts and Galaxy
digital recently let people know that
they're insiders at these various
Financial organizations believe that the
ETF application will be four to six
months away if we bring this back to
Rubenstein he's basically saying that
BlackRock is removing the career risk
for any other organization if you are a
large Financial organization on Wall
Street now you can get in the game
because Larry Fink and BlackRock did it
if we go back to 2020 we saw this
mechanism play out once before Stanley
druckermiller and Paul Tudor Jones they
came out publicly and said that they
supported Bitcoin that they owned
Bitcoin in their portfolio and they even
went as far as ptj saying that he
believed that Bitcoin would be the
fastest horse in the inflation bucket of
assets and he ended up being right but
once those two legends of Wall Street
said that they were into Bitcoin every
other portfolio manager on Wall Street
now had the ability to go and invest in
Bitcoin because career risk had been
removed the Legends did it and so now
anyone could do it we're watching the
same thing play out with BlackRock if
it's good enough for BlackRock it's good
enough for any other financial
institution David Rubinstein understands
his mechanism really well he realizes
that LPS or public shareholders of these
Asset Management firms are going to have
a lot less questions today if you go in
and allocate Capital to bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies then they would have
before BlackRock made this decision
career risk has been removed now there's
a green light for financial institutions
to start to allocate to bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and we have
multi-billionaires like David Rubinstein
talking about it as if it's any other
asset class stocks bonds or Bitcoin it's
pretty incredible to see how far we've
come in about 15 years but it's just
another signal that Bitcoin will
continue to be institutionalized by Wall
Street at the same time people outside
of the United States places where their
currency is failing inflation is
ravaging or there's risks around
censorship and caesarship they continue
to adopt Bitcoin as well most
Technologies are a top-down approach the
military and nation states go ahead and
create these technical analogies and
they adopt them first then it's
corporations and then it's individuals
Bitcoin is one of the special assets
which has been Bottoms Up individuals
adopted it first now we're seeing
corporations in large financial
institutions go ahead and get in the
game and eventually we will see every
nation state in the world adopt Bitcoin
as well in some form or fashion doesn't
mean that they will replace their
nation-state currency but they will use
it in some form or fashion whether it's
on their central bank balance sheet or
they actually allow their citizens to
pay taxes or each other with this
currency David Rubinstein is another
person that we now can put into the
supporter of Bitcoin category doesn't
mean that he necessarily went out and
bought hundreds of millions of dollars
in Bitcoin personally but it does mean
that he understands that the ground is
Shifting under the industry and Bitcoin
is going to continue to be a
institutional asset class moving forward
it already is worth hundreds of billions
of dollars and it likely will be worth
trillions of dollars in the future
as we see Mike novogratz David
Rubinstein BlackRock Fidelity and many
other large investors or Asset
Management firms come into the space you
have to remember that we need them we
need them to continue to push Bitcoin
forward whether we like it or not
Bitcoin and its holder base is changing
but that change isn't necessarily a bad
thing you just have to be aware of
what's happening it's amazing to see
David Rubenstein answer so many
questions about Bitcoin on National
Television in such an eloquent way I was
super impressed by it and if you get a
chance I highly suggest going and
watching the full interview hopefully
you enjoyed this update and I'll do more
of them in the future thanks so much for
watching this video if you liked it make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
like it so more people find it I'll
continue to crank out as many of these
as I can have a great day